- This episode of Legal Eagle
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking on the link
in the description.
In the last few weeks,
we've seen defenders
of this administration go from
there was absolutely no quid pro quo.
- There was no conditionality there,
there was no quid pro quo there.
- To it would only be a quid pro quo
if President Trump were
really thuggish about it.
- Graham was asked what he thought
would constitute
inappropriate quid pro quo,
saying "uh, hey pal, you know,
"you need to like, go after the Bidens
"or I ain't gonna give you any money.
"He'd be really like thuggish about it."
- To quid pro quos happen
all the time and in fact,
they're actually really good.
- What you just described
is a quid pro quo,
it is funding will not flow
unless the investigation
into the democratic
server happened as well.
- We do that all the
time with foreign policy.
- So what's the deal with quid pro quos?
Impeachable offense or
routine diplomacy tool?
(dramatic music)
Hey Legal Eagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer.
You all took Latin in high school, right?
Everyone knows the legal
definition of quid pro quo
and we can just all go home, right?
(buzzer buzzes)
No, you want me to talk about
why this is all relevant?
Okay fine, on October 22nd, Bill Taylor,
the top diplomat or charge
d'affaires to Ukraine
testified behind closed doors
before the House committees
that are leading the impeachment
inquiry of Donald Trump.
Taylor's full testimony
is currently unknown,
but news agencies got ahold
of Taylor's opening statement.
Now this was just Taylor's
opening statement,
but what he revealed,
and it basically stunned
everyone that's paying attention.
Taylor, you might recall,
was one of the diplomats
who was a party to a WhatsApp conversation
with US Special Envoy Kurt Volker
and US Ambassador to
the EU Gordon Sondland.
Volker turned over the
transcripts of those texts
to the House committees.
Taylor famously texted on September 9th,
"As I said on the phone, I
think it's crazy to withhold
"security assistance for help
with a political campaign,"
to when Gordon Sondland
replied five hours later,
"Bill I believe you are incorrect about
"President Trump's intentions.
"The president has been crystal clear,
"no quid pro quos of any kind.
"The president whether
Ukraine is truly going to
"adopt the transparency and reforms
"that President Zelensky
promised during his campaign.
"I suggest we stop the
back and forth by text.
"If you still have concerns,
I recommend you give
"Lisa Kenna or S a call to
discuss them directly, thanks."
Taylor was asked to testify as a witness
to the investigation into
the Trump administration's
efforts to pressure Ukrainian
President Volodymyr Zelensky
into opening an investigation
into repudiated allegations
of Ukraine's interference in the 2016
US presidential elections,
as well into the company Burisma
for the purpose of
eliciting or fabricating
dirt on Hunter Biden,
and by proxy, Joe Biden,
political candidate president
of the United States.
Taylor began his opening
statement by emphasizing
the importance of the
United States's relationship
with Ukraine, saying "our
national security demands
"that this relationship remain strong."
Taylor went on to say more about this,
noting that Ukraine now
and for the last five years
has been under attack from Russia,
and that the United
States security assistance
is crucial to Ukraine's
defense against Russia,
and that withholding security assistance
would be, quote, crazy.
And crazy is exactly what
Taylor would soon discover
on the part of the Trump administration.
In June, Taylor delivered a
letter from President Trump
to President Zelensky congratulating him
on his election victory and inviting him
to a meeting at the Oval Office.
This meeting was an
apparent goal for Zelensky,
but in order to obtain this goal,
Zelensky had to do some
things for Trump first.
For example, in a planned June 28th call
with Ukrainian president,
Ambassador Sondland,
quote, "did not wish
to include most of the
"regular inter agency participants,"
and, quote, "said that
he wanted to make sure
"no one was transcribing or monitoring
"as they added President
Zelensky to the call."
Taylor noted that a short time later,
it became abundantly
clear to him that, quote,
"the meeting President
Zelensky wanted was conditioned
"on the investigations of
Burisma and the alleged
"Ukrainian interference
in the 2016 US elections,"
and that this, quote,
irregular policy channel
was guided by Rudy Giuliani.
On July 18th, Taylor
learned from an individual
at the Office of Management
and Budget, the OMB,
that there was a hold on
security assistance to Ukraine.
This individual could not explain why
there was a hold, but Taylor
had a pretty good idea.
When Taylor inquired further,
the individual told him that
her boss had, quote,
"instructed her not to approve
"any additional spending
of security assistance
"for Ukraine until further notice."
This unidentified individual also relayed
that the directive for the hold had come
directly from President
Trump through Mick Mulvaney
to the OMB's chief of staff.
This is very, very bad, and
we'll talk about in a moment
this is strong evidence
for a quid pro quo.
In his statement, Taylor
went on to emphasize
how important US aid to Ukraine was
and how many more lives could
be lost if the hold remained.
He also noted that the
Secretary of Defense,
Secretary of State, the CIA Director,
and the National Security
Advisor all tried to sit down
with President Trump and
convince him to release the hold.
This sit-down, however, was quote,
"hard to schedule."
(buzzer buzzes)
What President Trump
wanted, Taylor discovered,
was for Zelensky to, quote,
"say that he will help
"the investigation and
address any specific
"personnel issues if there are any."
Trump's administration wanted
Zelensky to publicly announce
his participation in this investigation,
and they even tried to
give Zelensky a script
of what to say to Trump,
suggesting that he announce
that, quote, "I will
leave no stone unturned"
with regard to, quote "investigations,"
all the while making it look
like the US was uninvolved.
Zelensky's response, according
to Taylor, to all of this
was that he did not want to, quote,
"be used as a pawn in a
US reelection scheme."
This testimony paints a picture
of the Trump administration's motivations.
By withholding US aid,
they hope to get Zelensky
to announce his investigation
into Joe Biden's son
in the hopes that it would bolster
Trump's reelection campaign.
At this point, the clock was ticking
with regard to security
assistance to Ukraine.
Because of the way the US budget works,
if the funds weren't released
by the end of September,
they would essentially
expire and disappear,
not to mention the actual Ukrainians
whose lives were at stake.
In the last five years, 13,000
Ukrainians have been killed
by Russian soldiers,
and potentially dozens
of Ukrainian civilians
had been killed by Russia
during this time period.
Taylor was worried
especially because, quote,
"if the White House did not lift the hold
"prior to the end of the
fiscal year, September 30th,
"the funds would expire and
Ukraine would receive nothing."
As the wait went on, Ambassador
Sondland explicitly stated
that, quote, "the
security assistance money
"would not come until
President Zelensky committed
"to pursue the Burisma investigation."
Taylor's fears were confirmed.
This was the first time that he had heard
that security assistance,
not just a White House
Oval Office meeting was conditioned
on Zelensky committing
to investigating Burisma.
The bottom line is that Taylor testified
that one, there was in
fact a quid pro quo.
The White House conditioned the release
of $400 million of military
aid on Ukraine's statement
that they were opening
investigation into Burisma.
Number two, the order to withhold aid
came from the president himself.
Number three, this was
never about corruption,
it was about getting dirt
on Joe Biden and his son,
and number four, the
White House tried to hide
their involvement by scripting
Ukraine's announcement
and pretending that the investigations
had been Ukraine's idea all along.
It's of course always
important to take a step back
and look at the various players.
Everyone has bias, and
it's important to recognize
when you have two conflicting accounts.
Taylor is a career
diplomat who served in both
republican and democratic administrations,
so could he be too close to Ukraine?
Of course, interestingly,
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
specifically asked Taylor to essentially
come out of retirement to
help with the situation.
Taylor was essentially
President Trump's pick
to run diplomacy with the Ukraine.
Taylor acknowledged his
own bias and stated that
he wanted the US to support
Ukraine, and conditioned
his coming out of retirement
on that very fact.
On the other side of the coin,
there is Gordon Sondland who is a hotelier
who donated a million dollars
to Trump's inauguration.
Allegedly when Gordon Sondland testified
behind closed doors,
he did not recall most
of what Bill Taylor testified to,
although he doesn't appear
to outright contradict
anything that Bill Taylor actually said.
Taylor allegedly took
contemporaneous notes
throughout the affair.
In addition to Bill Taylor's testimony,
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Vindman,
an army officer assigned to
the National Security Council,
also testified recently.
He was one of the members of the NSC
that listened to the
infamous July 25th call
from the situation room.
According to his opening statement,
Vindman largely confirmed the
account of the whistleblower
and the readout that has
already been made public,
and which I covered in an earlier video.
Vindman testified in his opening statement
that he was, quote,
"concerned by the call,"
stating "I did not think
it was proper to demand
"that a foreign government
investigate a US citizen,
"and I was worried about the implications
"for the US government's
support of Ukraine.
"I realized that if Ukraine
pursued an investigation
"into the Bidens and
Burisma, it would likely be
"interpreted as a partisan
play which would undoubtedly
"result in Ukraine losing
the bipartisan support
"it had thus fair maintained.
"This would all undermine
US national security.
"Following the call, I again reported
"my concerns to NSC's lead counsel."
The New York Times is also reporting that
Vindman stated in his deposition,
which lasted 10 and a half hours,
and that's quite a long time,
that he requested several
changes to the wording
of the read-out of the call,
but that those changes were rejected
by the White House for unknown reasons.
Vindman also testified about
an earlier July 10th call
with Oleksandr Danylyuk, the
Secretary of the National
Security and Defense Council for Ukraine,
and National Security Advisor Bolton,
Ambassadors Volker and Sondland
and Energy Secretary Rick Perry.
Vindman testified that
during this July 10th call,
the meeting proceeded well
until the Ukrainians broached
the subject of a meeting
between the two presidents.
Ambassador Sondland started to speak about
delivering specific
investigations in order to
secure the meeting with the president,
at which time, Ambassador
Bolton cut the meeting short.
Following this meeting, there
was a scheduled debriefing
during which Ambassador
Sondland emphasized
the importance that Ukraine
deliver the investigations
into the 2016 election,
the Bidens, and Burisma.
I stated to Ambassador
Sondland that his statements
were inappropriate, that the
request to investigate Biden
and his son had nothing to
do with national security,
and that such investigations
were not something
the NSC was going to
get involved in or push.
Dr. Hill then entered
the room and asserted
to Ambassador Sondland that
his statements were inappropriate.
Following the debriefing
meeting, I reported my concerns
to the NSC's lead counsel.
Dr. Hill also reported the incident
So in general, Lieutenant
Colonel Vindman's testimony
backs up Bill Taylor's
and refutes the testimony
of Ambassador Gordon Sondland.
Additionally, there have
been attacks from the right
against Lieutenant Colonel Vindman
for his status as a Ukrainian immigrant
and allegations of dual loyalty,
despite the fact that he's a US citizen
and long-time member of the Army.
It's the clear that these
attacks or criticisms
are based on anything
more than speculation.
So that brings us to the quid pro quo.
Now of course, in the
famous Sondland text,
Sondland relayed that the
president has been crystal clear
that no quid pro quos of any kind,
but just because they claim
that doesn't necessarily
mean that it not a quid
pro quo arrangement.
As Taylor himself said in
response to this contention,
quote "President Trump did
insist that President Zelensky
"go to a microphone and say
he is opening investigations
"of Burisma and 2016
election interference,
"and that President Zelensky
would want to do this himself."
Quid pro quo translates
literally to this for that.
It is a type of exchange
where someone on one side
gives a thing of value to someone else
and expects something in
return from that person.
Whether a quid pro quo
is illegal and illicit
depends on the context.
If I give you five dollars
and you give me a book,
that's a quid pro quo, and
there's nothing wrong with that,
but things take a turn
when you're talking about
government officials using
power of their office
to extract a personal benefit.
Oftentimes, a quid pro quo
emerges in a governmental
setting when a government
official receives something
of personal value and
then abuses his or her
official power to give something in return
to that specific constituent who gave
some personal benefit to
that government official.
You can imagine a government
contractor who gives
a fancy new sports car
to a government official
who then steers a valuable
governmental contract
to that contractor, that
is a classic quid pro quo.
Illegal quid pro quo
arrangements also tend to pop up
in the workplace setting.
A quid pro quo would
exist where an employer
demands sexual favors in return for
an employee keeping their job.
So it depends on the context.
Mick Mulvaney has
recently been emphasizing
that especially in
foreign policy settings,
quid pro quo arrangements
happen all the time,
that's just the nature of foreign policy.
- We do that all the
time with foreign policy.
- I'll help you do this
if you help me do that.
Everyone is happy and secure.
For example, throughout the
history of the United States,
we have used our own aid
or assistance as leverage
for achieving things
such as democracy abroad,
an end to corruption,
and even physical access
to important geographical areas.
For example, President Jimmy
Carter provided Egypt with aid
in exchange for Egypt
making peace with Israel.
President Bush even demanded
that countries provide
free speech and freedom of assembly
before receiving certain US aid.
However, while this may be true,
quid pro quos that involve
a concerted self-interest
for a particular politician
do not happen all the time
in foreign policy, and quite frankly,
they really don't happen at all.
In fact, it was such a stunning admission
by mick Mulvaney to admit
that this was a quid pro quo
on behalf of the Trump administration,
ostensibly for President Trump,
that it elicited an
almost immediate walk-back
from Mulvaney and the rest
of the administration.
This arrangement between
the Trump administration
and President Zelensky of Ukraine
falls into the problematic
category of quid pro quos
for a couple of reasons.
First of all, such an
arrangement is probably
highly illegal and may be sufficient
to prove the crimes of bribery
and election interference.
While it was would admittedly
difficult to indict
and convict a president of these crimes
for reasons that we've already
talked about on this channel,
in order to establish a
prima facie case for bribery
under 18 USC 201, one
would have to prove that
a public official, in
this case President Trump,
directly or indirectly corruptly demanded
anything of value personally,
in this case bolstering
his reelection campaign,
in return for being
influenced in the performance
of any official act, in this case,
releasing money that
Congress and the Pentagon
had already appropriated for Ukraine.
Or you can take, for
example, 51 USC 30121,
which states that "it shall
be unlawful for a foreign
"national, directly or
indirectly, to make a contribution
"or donation of money
or other thing of value
"or to make an express or implied promise
"to make a contribution
or donation in connection
"with a federal, state,
or local election."
In this case, one would
argue that the thing of value
is investigating a political rival,
which obviously the Trump administration
would try to lord over
the head of Joe Biden
as he tries to secure
the democratic nomination
for potentially running for
President of the United States in 2020.
Additionally and apart from
whether any of these acts
fit the neat statutory
definitions of these crimes,
and overcome the constitutional issues
in terms of indicting a sitting president,
this arrangement is problematic because
it essentially means that the
President of the United States
is subverting the national interest
for his own personal interest.
In other words, he's putting himself
above the entire country.
Now, no one argues that
Hunter Biden's status
as a board member of Burisma
doesn't smack of nepotism,
but strong-arming a sovereign
nation into investigating
a conspiracy theory about
Ukrainian computer servers
and ginning up a defunct
investigation into Burisma
appears to serve President Trump only,
and not US national interest.
It appears motivated
primarily if not solely
to help President Trump get reelected
and not to help America.
Rudy Giuliani tweets
the quiet part out loud
when he tweeted "with all the fake news,
"let me make it clear
that everything I did
"was to discover evidence
to defend my client
"against false charges.
"Dems would be horrified
by the attacks on me,
"if my client was a terrorist,
but they don't believe
"real Donald Trump has rights."
The problem here is that at
the request of the president,
Rudy Giuliani was running his own shadow
foreign policy operation,
and he's admitting that
in this context, he wasn't
acting on behalf of America,
but acting on behalf of
his client, Donald Trump,
in trying to get dirt
against a political rival.
If this had been in America's
interest, President Trump
would have used the usual
diplomatic channels,
gone through the Mutual
Legal Assistance Treaty
and avoided using an entirely separate
clandestine shadow foreign
policy team led by Rudy Giuliani.
This kind of arrangement
pressuring Ukraine
to do something to benefit
President Trump personally
in exchange for $400 million
in US aid and assistance
is what appears to be an abuse of power
and an attempt to use one's
official capacity as president
(bell dings)
for personal gain.
Now some, including former
acting Attorney General
Matthew Whitaker have argued that
an abuse of power is not a crime.
- What evidence of a crime do you have?
I mean, the constitution,
you know, sort of,
abuse of power is not a crime.
The constitution is very
clear that this has to be
some pretty egregious behavior.
- However, such an abuse of
power is a crucial inquiry
as far as impeachment is concerned.
That's because impeachment was designed
to dismantle this kind of abuse of power.
Ironically, Bill Taylor
came out of retirement
at the request of Mike
Pompeo to help Ukraine.
Now he'll probably want to
go back into retirement,
and now that he has
more time on his hands,
maybe he'll finally
listen to his grandkids
and join Instagram after
taking Brandon Woelfel's class
Instagram-Worthy Photography,
Shoot, Edit, and Share.
Or maybe he will finally
tackle all those chores
around the house his wife asked him to do,
like redesigning his family room.
He could really use Emily Henderson's
Skillshare class Style Your Space,
Creative Tips and Techniques
for Interior Design.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has tens of thousands
of classes on everything,
like music, design,
lifestyle, and technology.
It's great for former top
diplomats who suddenly
find themselves with a lot
more time on their hands.
A yearly membership is
less than $10 per month,
but Legal Eagles will get two free months
of Skillshare when you
click on the link below.
Plus it really helps out this channel.
The free premium membership gives you
unlimited access to must-know topics
so you can improve your
skills and learn new things
all free for two months.
So improve yourself now
while you are waiting
to give your own congressional testimony
before the House impeachment inquiry.
Do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out my other
real law reviews over here
when I talk about the whistleblower,
hearsay objections to
the impeachment inquiry,
and tons of other breaking news,
and as always, I will see you in court.